les arbres sont chargés de symbole
depuis très très longtemps
c'est pas très précis pour une
historienne mais longtemps et l'arbre
auquel on va s'intéresser aujourd'hui
est particulièrement important dans la
mythologie nordique puisque c'est juste
l'arbre des mondes
le centre du monde coeur de tout ce qui
est sacré pour les scandinaves la
théorie la plus répandue sur son nom
donne la traduction de destrier dodin y
est l'un des nombreux noms attribués au
dieu odin signifie aussi le redoutable
le reste de son nom pourrait signifier
jb or un jb peut aussi être désigné
comme le cheval du pendu ce qui donne le
nom final de cheval ou destrier dodin la
raison de ce nom et que c'est en restant
neuf jours et 9 mai pendu à une branche
de ligue grade il caudin aurait
découvert le sens des rues il est
généralement représenté comme un naïf
parfois un frêne son principal symbole
est celui de la vie de ses branches il
s'étend à l'infini vers l'espace alors
que ses racines pénètre dans la terre et
relie les mondes entre eux venons en à
ces mondes justement d'après les lacie
les graciles permet de relier les neuf
froid yom de la mythologie nordique
parce qu'il repose sur lui l'une de ses
racines la plus grosse s'étend des races
garde le royaume des dieux à une autre
la plus nombreuse mais new times le
royaume des géants des glaces la
troisième racines la plus puissante
passe au dessus du nifff i'm royaume des
brumes et des morts il est aussi connu
sous le nom de niederungen ou encore
qu'elle aille bien qu'on les désigne
aussi parfois comme deux royaumes
distincts les autres royaumes sont
d'anaheim le royaume des dieux vannes
alfheim le royaume des elfes de lumière
sartel fine au royaume des ailes ce sont
2000 garde nous royaume des hommes et le
moose prime le royaume du feu l'oreille
au menu on trouve des mentions de l'ec
razil dans différentes étapes poétique
du xiiie siècle dans le poème volluz pas
la prêtresse vole va dit se souvenir des
temps anciens où les phrases ils
n'étaient qu'une graine puisqu'on parle
des débuts de l'hydrazine allant
directement à sa fin et au sort qui
attend durant le ragnarok la fin du
monde pour les scandinaves les grades il
tremble fremm qui se dresse le vieil
arbre grogne et le géant se libère dans
le poème gilf à binning il est décrit
comme le chef lieu saint des dieux où
ces derniers se réunissent chaque jour
pour tenir leurs cours un autre poème
que je vais conserver en anglais pour
ses rimes tout en sous titrant bien sûr
est aussi récité par la volvo 1 h à
laudun
channing l'homme fort des combats de new
york devant les stands for heroes going
rogue soir car les gazelles n'est pas
qu'un arbre il forme un tout avec les
différentes sources qui coule entre ses
racines
la première source se trouve près du nid
fly mais se nomme vers guelmim
elle est gardée par un dragon liefooghe
qui ronge perpétuellement la racine qui
en sort
la deuxième source nomme la fontaine de
minuit elle se trouve sous la racine qui
mène au yachting règle elle est gardée
par la tête maintenue en vie dieu me
lire
doté d'une grande sagesse on raconte que
quiconque boileau de cette source avec
la corne gala obtiendra lieu aussi
intelligence et sagesse c'est ce que
fait ou d'un mec doit pour cela ouvrir
un de ses yeux en échange
enfin la troisième source se nomme
ouvrent elles se trouvent sous la racine
data de ces deux ans tel que les yeux se
rassemblent avant de franchir de bifrost
ce qui leur permet de se rendre dans les
autres royaumes cette source est gardé
par l'énorme trois femmes qui prennent
soin de l'arbre en tirons de l'eau
chaque jour de la source pour la mêlée à
la terre et on faire une bouffe et ils
vont pas enduisent le tronc de l'arbre
ces normes se nomme pour le passé vers
vendit le présent et schools le futur et
ont pour autre rôle de fixer la durée de
vie de tous on peut déjà constater les
nombreuses vies qui repose sur l'arbre
mais ce ne sont pas les seuls les grades
il abrite aussi de nombreux animaux qui
vaille à sa santé ou au contraire
participe à la souffrances qu'ils
endurent des serpents venimeux attaque
ses racines
les poulains sauvage dévore ses
bourgeons chacun essayant de l'empêcher
de s'étendre
la chèvre à hydro mais plusieurs serbes
vivent aussi dans ses branches et se
nourrissent de ces feuilles et de signes
se baigne dans la source tourner en tant
qu arbre de vie il est toujours en
fleurs les gouttes de rosée qui tombe de
ses branches tombent sur terre sous
forme de miel pour nourrir les abeilles
même si c'est pas très logique sur la
plus haute branche tient l'aigle vie
devenir et entre les yeux de cet aigle
se tient le flou combettes faut venir à
eux deux ils surveillent le monde nuit
et jour enfin au pied de l'arbre vives
de dragon qui cherche sa destruction ni
drogue que j'ai déjà présenté et maureen
tout le long de l'arbre pour celui qui
maintient à la fois la cohésion et la
discorde dans cet univers ratatosk
l'écureuil qui n'a de cesse de monter
jusqu'aux plus hautes branches pour
redescendre jusqu'aux racines afin de
provoquer un combat entre les rapaces au
sommet
et les serpents et dragons qui occupent
les racines de l'arbre il représente la
discorde la guerre car c'est ainsi que
les grades il représente pleinement la
vie elle n'est pas synonyme de paix même
si l'arbre cherche à la maintenir mais
elle est aussi grouillante soumises aux
risques de la guerre et de la mort
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
j'espère que les deux vidéos d'avril
vous ont plu le gentil nama d'as sur
gertrude bell et celle ci je rappelle au
passage que on a un eu lui qui est lancé
pour la web série que j'ai écrite et qui
sera tourné cet été et vous pouvez
retrouver le lien
bon à la fin ou génériques comme
l'habitude nord est puis dans la
description aussi
et n'hésitez pas à partager tout a et b
à mettre des pousses bleus a participé
au nul si vous le voulez et à le
partager
j'ai déjà dit bref merci pour tout à
bientôt en mai pour un chronique de
profs et bonne journée
[Musique]
il faut aussi que c'est assez